looking for something to do possibly
with the family this weekend
you could take game night on the road jc
fernandez live in chinatown at game nest
arcade
there's really something there for
everyone hi jc
hey kirsten there really is it's so cool
here because you walk in here
it's just 10 bucks and you get an hour
of free play unlimited
unlimited play on any game you want you
actually get a little pager here
to let you know when your hour is up
this is abraham he is the owner and you
were telling me abraham
that this game right here is one of the
rarest games in the country why is that
so this is the only game in the country
ever it's initially
zero it's basically only based out of
japan and you can't find it anywhere
else in the united states
now you were telling me people were
driving in from california to play a
driving game
california utah you name it they come
from everywhere all over the world
all sorts of carg people that love the
car sheet
love this game and love everything about
it there are games wall-to-wall games
let's take a walk down this aisle this
is like the um
this is like driver's row here because
of all the driving games and
here's a classic how many of you play
mario kart at home you can come down
here and play mario kart the arcade game
huh
yeah absolutely mario kart 2 gp is one
of our best selling games here at game
nest
it's great for the family all ages now a
lot of these games are from
japan and down here we have pikachu
because this year is the 25th
anniversary of pokemon
absolutely february 27th is with pikachu
day actually
that's what they call it i've never seen
a table flip game how does this one work
let me show you guys right here
check this out it's a very simple game
actually
so this is something that you call table
flip game it's you actually get to flip
the actual table
and enrage everybody around you it's
very simple
very easy to use gotta speak a little
bit of japanese but just keep hitting
start you'll get through the whole thing
real quick you've been probably angry at
a dinner party you want to flip that
table over this is your chance to come
down and do it through an arcade what
are you gonna what are you gonna flip
for abraham right here we're gonna flip
a wedding cake if
a few brides have ever been upset at
your husbands this is the game to play
[Applause]
[Music]
and you're flipping tables you're only
gonna find that game here at game ness i
guarantee you're not going to find that
anywhere in las vegas
we got pikachu and look at this one back
here this day this dance dance
revolution turn around
what's the dancing one abraham yeah
dance uh puff it up pump it up extreme
we get people
all day long play it non-stop it's a lot
of fun it's a high
energy pace you'll definitely won't find
someone that's not fit playing that game
i love it down here this there's
something for the entire family you have
all the safety protocols in place you
sanitize everything you have special
ventilation
going on absolutely we have hepa filters
as you can see right there between ddr
and pump it up
it's all throughout the store everything
safety in here we don't want anybody to
be feel
unsafe or unhappy abraham we appreciate
it thank you so much and pikachu
thank you we appreciate it back to you
guys in the studio
pikachu is pretty darn excited there jc
25 year anniversary coming up all right
look at jc with all his energy man ah
we got to get some of that energy ted
yeah we do yes
and i wonder if they have spy hunter
remember spy hunter
no i don't remember you and i would
really do well i think
like at teenage mutant ninja turtles or
donkey kong
or pac-man i love the original donkey
kong that's
it yeah we're gonna bring the energy for
that for sure right
and also our